We look at a lot of Allouni clips on this
program.
So it really takes a lot for me to say this.
I have for you today one of the most outrageous
clips I've seen in years, and it is from right
wing propaganda channel Newsmax.
And it involves the my pillow guy, Mike Lyndell.
Now, I won't do a big lead up, but I want
to make sure we're all on the same page.
If you've been following politics for the
last year, you might know that my pillow is
a company that sells pillows on right wing
media, I believe even pajamas as well.
And the founder, Mike Lyndell, is a right
wing religious nut who thinks Donald Trump
was or is a gift from God to the American
people.
Lyndell somehow because this country is so
backwards, ended up in a position of proximity
to power.
He was actually close to Donald Trump.
He was advising Trump about how to possibly
stay in power despite having lost the election
to Joe Biden.
Michael Lyndell appeared on Newsmax yesterday
and started spouting off about Dominion voting
systems, which didn't go well because Newsmax,
like many other networks and Rudy Giuliani
and others, Newsmax has been threatened by
Dominion with a lawsuit if they keep repeating
these false claims about Dominion voting systems.
So the hosts, when Mike Lyndell brings up
Dominion voting, the hosts try to change topics.
And it doesn't go well.
Mike Lyndell just keeps talking.
It culminated with one of the hosts walking
off the set.
But first, when Mike Lyndell brings up Dominion,
the hosts start saying, we can't verify any
of this, clearly trying to avoid a lawsuit.
But Mike Lyndell just keeps going.
So for what happened with your Twitter account
and the company page?
Well, first mine was taken down because we
have all the election fraud with so many machines.
We have a hundred percent proof.
And then I when they took it down my site,
I moved it back up my personal.
I put it it was my thank you very much.
My mike.
You're talking about machines that Newsmax
had not been able to verify any of those kinds
of allegations.
We just want to let people know that there's
nothing substantive that we've seen.
And let me read you something there.
While there were some clear evidence of some
cases of voter fraud and election irregularities,
the election results in every state were certified.
And Newsmax accepts the results as legal and
final.
The courts have also supported that view.
So, OK, so he gets that on the record.
But Mike Lyndell doesn't care.
He will not be dissuaded from talking about
Dominion voting systems.
Let's keep going.
And it just continues to escalate.
We wanted to talk to you about canceling culture,
if you will.
We don't want to relitigate the wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
You're making money because we understand
where you are.
So let me ask you this.
Do you think that this should be temporary
because it appears to be permanent?
Could you make an argument that it is temporary?
What could you make an argument that this
could be a temporary banning rather than permanent?
No, I wanted to be a permanent because you
know what they did, because I'm reviewing
all the evidence on Friday of all the election
that these machines.
So I'm sorry.
OK, now, Mike, can I ask our producers, can
we get out of here, please?
I don't want to have to keep going over this.
We're not going to verify any of those allegations.
So absolute and complete chaos.
One of the funniest news clips that I've seen
and hear in this last segment, if you're listening,
you might hear noise as the host walks off.
If you're watching, you will see the host
just walk right off the set or you might hold
on a everybody.
Hold on a second, Mike.
Mike, hold on one second.
Let's talk a little bit about just what is
happening overall in terms of censorship and
sort of my company and myself in this country
council culture.
So by that point by point, one of the hosts
is just gone outrageous and amazing.
And the real question is, why do they keep
having Mike Lyndell on at all?
They know that this is lyndell shtick.
Newsmax sees the billion dollar lawsuits by
Dominion against Rudy Giuliani and others.
They got a threat letter themselves saying
stop these defamatory claims.
And they decided as a company, hell, no, we
can't afford that.
So then why do you have Mike Lyndell on when
you know that that's what he's been talking
about for months now?
And I want to be really, really clear.
This is not about ethics.
Newsmax is depraved and horrible.
They are willing to spread anything.
And in fact, for a month or six weeks after
the November election, they welcomed every
one of these lunatics on Sydney, Powell, Rudy,
you know, whoever to talk about dominion,
to talk about voter fraud, massive voter dumps,
all of this different stuff.
This is not about ethics.
It's about money.
I don't think I've ever seen defamation claims
and warnings used as effectively as we've
seen Dominion used them in response to right
wing media.
They have right wing media hosts literally
walking away when the topic of Dominion voting
machines is brought up.
They're they're asking producers cut his mike
because they've so effectively been notified.
We will sue you if you keep allowing this
stuff on the air.
And I think the most important takeaway is
there's a few there's a few important takeaways
here.
Take away number one.
How insane is this country that the my pillow
guy became close to the president because
of his ideas about how to steal an election?
And as I've said before, Trump saying I'm
running wouldn't have done the damage it did.
We're not the American electorate or at least
part of it, so susceptible to a con, an obvious
con man like Donald Trump in the same way
Mike Lyndell, wanting to be an adviser to
the president would be meaningless if we didn't
have a president who thought it was a good
idea and that that's one take away.
The other is I've said it, but I want to say
it again.
Newsmax is not concerned with the truth all
of a sudden.
And that's why they're saying to Mike, Lendell,
don't talk about dominion.
They're scared of the lawsuit.
They knew the truth from day one, which was
Joe Biden won the election.
That's it.
But they kept airing this crap because it
got them clicks.
But now the risk of a billion dollar lawsuit
is too big for the revenue they were probably
making on YouTube or wherever else by repeating
the stuff.
So an immensely compelling clip to watch and
think about.
I mean, if what you're saying is too outrageous
for Newsmax to air, you know, it's bad and
you know that you're
off
the deep end.